voilà donc ce qui se passe sur le plan
national mais pour nous habitants
d'ile-de-france la sécurité sociale
c'est autre chose
des organismes auxquels on verse de
l'argent qu'ils nous en donnent parfois
est une organisation assez compliquée
dans laquelle dominique bâillon essaie
d'y voir clair
la sécurité sociale tout le monde
connaît mais on ignore généralement la
complexité de cet organisme créé
officiellement en 1947
si l'on fait le compte des régimes celui
des différentes branches et si l'on
rapporte cela au niveau régional ou
départemental
on arrive en fait un total de plusieurs
centaines de caisses différentes mais
laissons de côté les particularités la
sécurité sociale c'est avant tout aux
yeux du grand public l'assurance maladie
elle intéresse en région parisienne non
compris la seine-et-marne
administrativement à part 5 millions
d'assurés plus 3 millions d'ayants droit
pour ces 8 millions de personnes
les allocations les dépenses de santé
qu'il faut rembourser représente chaque
année des sommes très importantes 20
milliards en 76 23 ans 77 et 27 ans 78
soit une augmentation de 33 % en deux
ans ou grandes caisses régionales celles
de l'assurance vieillesse
elle concerne un million trois cent
mille personnes là aussi les dépenses
progressent très vite 9 pinière en 75 11
176 et 14 ans 77
enfin un troisième grande caisse les
allocations familiales dont les
prestations s'élèvent pour la région à 6
milliards répartis entre 850 mille
familles les allocations familiales
demeure la seule caisse bénéficiaires
elle continue au nom du grand principe
de la solidarité nationale à combler en
partie le déficit des autres régimes
un déficit qui s'accroît d'année en
année
la difficulté réside dans l'écart qui
existe entre la croissance des
prestations et la croissance des
recettes les recettes des régimes de
sécurité sociale sont constitués de
cotisation et par conséquent suivent
l'évolution des salaires et salaires
s'accroissent actuellement d'environ 11
ou 12% par an alors que les prestations
croissent de 18 ou 19 % suivant les
branches évident que c'était car génère
constamment là déficit
il est très difficile de prévoir d'une
année sur l'autre l'importance du
déficit de la sécurité sociale 2 ou 3
milliards c'est presque une goutte d'eau
par rapport aux 280 milliards du budget
total du régime général
il suffit que les salaires progressent
moins vite que prévu ou qu'un hiver
rigoureux entraîne des dépenses de santé
supplémentaires pour que le déficit
passe du simple au double et puis bien
sûr il faut essayer de combler ce
déficit
on aura peut-être la solution de ce
problème mercredi proche